Let's talk about Dr.
Anthony Foushee.
Dr. Anthony Foushee has to be very careful
in his role on the White House Coronavirus
Task Force, in his role as the top infectious
disease doctor in the United States.
He's always there.
He's on TV.
He's at many of Trump's press briefings.
He's being interviewed all the time.
And he is an actual doctor, meaning that the
things he says are typically true when they're
within his area of expertise, which is infectious
disease that is very different than Donald
Trump.
But when Foushee was asked in an interview
a few weeks ago, why aren't you publicly contradicting
Trump when he tells his lies?
Foushee essentially said, This is my paraphrase.
Foushee said, You know, it's not realistic
for me to step in front of him at the podium
every time he says something that's wrong
and say, no, no, no.
And it sort of seems
like Foushee recognizes that his presence
is more important than contradicting Trump
at every opportunity.
And we've even seen Foushee in some moments
express exasperation visibly.
One of those moments was when Donald Trump
mentioned the deep state during a press briefing
and Dr. Foushee literally face palmed, incredulous
about what Donald Trump was saying at a more
recent press conference.
Dr. Foushee was directly asked.
Here's what the president says about hydroxy
chloroquine.
Can you comment about it?
And Trump literally did not allow Dr. Foushee
to answer the question, and Foushee looked
very uncomfortable.
But finally, Dr Foushee has made it clear
that were it not for Donald Trump's actions,
we might have been able to save people.
And Donald Trump is immediately signaling
that he may be preparing to fire Dr. Foushee.
Let's go through it step by step.
This is from CNN.
Now, remember, we have
to have realistic expectations about what
Anthony Foushee will say about he's not going
to insult Trump.
He's not going to say Trump failed us.
But Dr. Foushee admitted and this is something
that they've not yet been clear about.
Dr. Foushee admits if we had taken this more
seriously earlier, we would have saved lives.
Take a look at the video from CNN.
The New York Times reported yesterday that
you and other top officials wanted to recommend
social and physical distancing guidelines
to President Trump.
As far back as the third week of February.
But the administration didn't announce such
guidelines to the American public until March
16th, almost a month later.
You know, Jake, as I've said many times, we
look at it from a pure health standpoint.
We make a recommendation.
Often the recommendation is taken.
Sometimes it's not.
But we it is what it is.
We are where we are right now.
Do you think lives could have been saved if
social distancing, physical distancing?
Stay at home measures had started.
Third week of February instead of mid-March.
Jake, again, it's the what would have what
could have.
It's very difficult to to go back and say
that.
I mean, obviously, you could logically say
that if you had a process that was ongoing
and you started mitigation earlier, you could
have saved lives.
Obviously, no one is going to deny that.
But what goes into those kinds of decisions
is complicated.
But you're right.
I mean, obviously, if we add right from the
very beginning, shut everything down, it may
have been a little bit different, but there
was a lot of pushback about shutting things
down back then.
Do you think lives could have been saved?
Yes, they could have been it.
Dr. Foushee.
He uses non-confrontational language.
But this is a big deal because Donald Trump
has been insisting and continues to insist
there was nothing he could possibly have done
differently.
There was nothing he could possibly have done
earlier.
No matter what he had known, had he read those
memos?
He didn't read no matter what.
He did everything.
As soon as it could have been done and nothing
could have been done differently.
Trump has denied the notion that if he had
acted earlier, lives would have been saved.
Despite the reality that, you know, you don't
really need to be a doctor to realize that
that's not true.
Also important was that Anthony Foushee said
we make recommendations.
The recommendations are always taken for Anthony
Fouty's temperament.
That is him saying, we told
Trump and he ignored us.
We can't expect Dr. Foushee to make direct
attacks.
We can't expect him to behave like Trump does.
But this is a doctor making it clear recommendations
were made.
They were not followed.
If they had been followed, we would have fewer
deaths right now.
But remember, on a per capita basis, it's
not even close.
In South Korea, South Korea's population is
smaller than ours.
But importantly, both countries had their
first cases right around February 20th.
Matter of hours separating the two.
On a per capita basis, our case rate is seventeen
hundred cases per million.
Theirs is two hundred and five.
That's not an error.
Seventeen hundred versus 2 0 5.
As Dr. Foushee says, the heterogeneity of
the population may be a factor.
Doesn't explain a 9 X difference.
Moving early does.
And they moved early.
Our test rate is eighty
five hundred per million.
There is this ten thousand per million.
We have a 20 percent lower test rate.
And of course, that's now bearing in mind
that they were that high much, much earlier.
And it's reflected in the death toll.
Our death rate is 67 per million.
South Korea's is four.
That's not an error.
Their death rate is four people per million.
Ours is 67.
Our death rate is almost 17 times higher than
South Korea's.
Now, unfortunately, Trump appears to be signaling
he may be ready to fire Dr. Foushee after
this statement came out yesterday from Dr.
Foushee.
If we had moved earlier, we could have saved
people.
Trump retweeted a tweet from a lady named
Diane Laraine who said Foushee is now saying
that had Trump listened to the medical experts
earlier, he could have saved more lives.
She was telling people on February
29 that there was nothing to worry about and
it posed no threat to the U.S. public at large.
Time to fire Foushee Trump re-tweeting that
and adding that it is all fake news.
There is very clearly little tolerance for
dissension in the ranks.
It seems Dr. Foushee may soon be fired by
Donald Trump.
I hope it doesn't happen if we do do it.
If we do lose Dr. Foushee.
It is going to get even worse.
We will see if Dr. Foushee is there today
at the White House coronavirus press briefing,
but it is not looking good.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman to
see the start of my 2020 urban garden.
Plenty of time for gardening.
Given that I don't leave my house, we'll take
a quick break and be back with much
more
right after this